the next batch of free games for
PlayStation Plus essential subscribers
has leaked and at this point PlayStation
should just start announcing the lineup
earlier even though it still might leak
earlier and then they'd have to announce
it even earlier than that and then let's
get to the games the February freebies
include Ali Ali World Evil Dead the game
Mafia Definitive Edition and Destiny 2
Beyond light the leak also noted that
Mafia Definitive Edition might not be
available in all regions if that's the
case for you the leaker claimed that a
different game would be substituted in
mafia's place the whole lineup should be
available to claim starting February 7th
and if you keep up with PlayStation's
monthly free games then you might notice
this time around it's a little different
because we're getting four games instead
of the usual three it seems likely that
an exception to the rule has been made
because of the looming launch of Destiny
2 lightfall a brand new major expansion
that arrives for the game on February
28th and with that in mind PlayStation
is giving away Destiny 2B on light an
expansion that released in 2020. if
you're new to Destiny 2 you can download
the base game for free and then check
out Beyond light to see if you're
interested in picking up the other
Destiny 2 expansions both the
PlayStation 4 and 5 versions of Beyond
light will be free my favorite game on
this list is Ali Ali world and if you
missed it last year when it launched you
should definitely give it a try when it
drops on PlayStation Plus this side
scrolling skateboarding game has
fast-paced actions slick handles and an
Eclectic assortment of levels and
challenges not to mention some cool
customization a really good soundtrack
as well meanwhile Evil Dead is an online
survival horror game that falls into the
steadily growing asymmetric multiplayer
genre it launched last year two
generally favorable reviews so it could
be a good fit if you're searching for a
new game to play with your friends for
those who like an open world Vibe but
think they're sometimes too much to do
Mafia Definitive Edition will be
refreshing a great remake of the 2002
original Mafia infinitive Edition takes
a streamlined open world approach as it
solely focuses on story missions
scattered across its world and in other
PlayStation news a new ad for the PS5
was uploaded to the console's official
YouTube channel and Uncharted fans are
hopeful that it's hinting at a new
adventure in the franchise the live from
PS5 ad shows live action versions of
multiple games in the PS5 library in a
local news format we see glimpses of
Spider-Man Eloy from Horizon Kratos and
atreus from God of War and many more
however among the rapid fire scenes
shown towards the end of the video a
young girl is shown holding a torch in a
dark cave with a shiny object on a
pedestal in front of her eagle-eyed
Twitter users immediately picked up on
these scenes which led to speculation
that a new Uncharted game starring
Nathan and Elena's daughter Cassie might
be in development Sony has not
officially commented on these rumors as
of the recording of this video this new
sequel if it does exist will likely not
be developed by series Creator naughty
dog with Studio head Neil druckman
saying the team was quote done with the
franchise however druckman has also
stated that he would be open to another
team taking the reins as long as they
quote get the essence of it right this
would not be the first time that Sony
has teased an upcoming release in this
manner as VGC points out a symbol
familiar to Resident Evil 4 fans
appeared in a PlayStation ad in 2021
nine full months before our E4 remake
was revealed in a PlayStation state of
play presentation hit the comment
section and let me know which studio you
think should take over the Uncharted
franchise and I'll see you tomorrow
foreign